wo bleibst ja ich schreib nur noch
schnell dass ich bei Ikea für
Weihnachten pa AK mit ach so ja alles
klar nehme nur ein paar
AK wir schreib AK was keine Ahnung AK
s Korrekturprogramm ja schon aber da
kommt immer gleich
akneaste go ja spinst du da wde ja die
ganzen nächsten Wochen zugemüllt mit
Werbung für AK was so stimmt wier du
schreibst einfach ganz was anders
schreib Kleinzeug
Kleinzeug ja ich bin no bei Ikea und
besorge für Weihnachten Kleinzeug das
checken die doch sofort die merken doch
sofort die AK was zum Schreiben so stimm
schreib die schreiben l damit ich nicht
bin
stimmt sch ja du und W Weihnachten
einfach selber was basteln ja so
Kleinzeug ist total gute Idee ja hast
Lust
ne und wenn wir einfach gar keine akzess
besorgen sondern irgendwas anders Kekse
ja
Keke serviertin und Serv
nur Kiki plus Kiki
[Applaus]
genau